Yeah, if you sing about killing your girlfriend all the time
and then your girlfriend shows up decomposing in your Tesla,
probably you did it.
No dry snitching. >> Listen, huge news, guys. Huge news,
okay? Massive news.
arrested for the murder of Celeste Rivas. Celeste Rivas, okay?
This is the girl that David was accused of killing. He did actually
kill her. He has been arrested. It is over, okay?
They found him. They found out. Well, I mean, I assume, you know,
technically alleged, technically innocent until proven guilty,
but hey. I mean, basically everybody assumed this was the guy.
They said for a while that he wasn't a suspect. Now, it turns
out he's actually arrested. He has actually been arrested now.
David is in police custody after being arrested for the murder
of 14-year-old girl of the 14-year-old girl Celeste
The singer was arrested Tuesday, according to the Los Angeles
Police Department. Oh, they held this in for like a day and a
half. Crazy.
Cops say detectives from LAPD's robbery homicide division made
the arrest and David is being held without bail. Our sources
tell us he was arrested at the LA home where he's been staying.
The LA County District Attorney tells TMZ, "Our office is aware
of the arrest of David Anthony Burke by the Los Angeles Police
Department. The case is expected to be presented to the Major
Crimes Division, at which point prosecutors will review the facts
and evidence to determine whether there is sufficient evidence
to file charges. At this time, additional information is not
available. We will share an update on Monday once a filing decision
has been made."
David's arrest comes over 7 months after Celeste's body was found
decomposing in his Tesla. The body was discovered way back in
September 2025 when David was in the middle of the tour and he
quickly scrapped his remaining shows and receded from public
view. We covered this. We knew about this, right? As the death
investigation played out, our law enforcement sources told us
the LAPD considered David a suspect. And in November, a grand
jury was convened with Los Angeles County Deputy District Beth
Silverman presenting the case.
mugshot, Neo Langston.
I don't know how this guy's related. David's arrest comes after
the grand jury heard testimony from multiple witnesses in his
orbit, including his day-to-day manager, Robert Morgenroth.
No [snorts] way. And his close friend, streamer Neo Langston.
Oh, I see. LAPD sources have told TMZ David made a mysterious
trip to a remote area of Santa Barbara in the middle of the night
last spring, and they believe that it's somehow connected to
Celeste's
Authorities believe David, who's now 21, had a relationship with
Celeste, who was 14 when her body was found. Celeste's funeral
was held October 6th at Queen and Heaven or Queen of Heaven Cemetery
and mortuary in Rowland Heights, California, where family and
friends said their last goodbyes. David's Tesla has been abandoned
in the or had been abandoned in the Hollywood Hills for a few
days before it was towed to a Hollywood impound lot September
5th, and on September 8th, cops found the body after getting
reports of a foul odor coming from the car. And she was wearing
black leggings and a tube top, plus two pieces of jewelry, a
metal stud earring and a metal chain bracelet in the shape of
a W.
Authorities said she had a tattoo on her right index finger with
the letters shh, and David has the same ink on his right index
finger. Police have not revealed who was driving the Tesla before
it was found abandoned and impounded. The Tesla had not been
reported stolen. So, this is the missing poster for Celeste.
Okay? The girl's mom told us her daughter went missing in April
2024 and had a boyfriend named David. David's government name
is
David Anthony Burke. Okay?
Dude, 2024
was when she was killed and they arrested this guy
April 2026.
Damn, that is Now, we didn't start hearing about this until she
was found in September of Was it Sept- There's no way it was
September 2024, right? It was 2025 when she was found, wasn't
it?
Yeah, September 2025 was when she was found. So, she must have
been gone living with David for a while, right? Like abducted
in some way and living with David for a while.
And then and then for a year she was missing, they'd not seen
her. And then eventually, yeah, eventually she goes missing missing
again and
September 2025. Okay, hold on. Did Did they say September 5th
is around time of death? No, that's when it was towed. Okay.
Did they have like Has there ever been anything published on
when they think she was killed? I think there was something like
this, no? That basically you found out where the car got moved.
Like you could see it on Google Maps. The car had been like sitting
there for months, right? Weeks or months? 8-minute video. So,
what happened to David? Let's see what we got out of this It's
from 3 weeks ago. So, very, very timely video. I'm guessing this
guy is about to blow the [__] up in the algo cuz
everybody's going to want to watch this, right? >> Possibly
the biggest news in music of this year. But David had some crazy
allegations against him, and it feels like we just haven't heard
anything from anyone about it at all. Like is he a suspect? Did
he get arrested? What's going on? Well, in case you forgot, let
me briefly refresh your memory. Basically, David was a guy who
was very popular for making songs like Romantic Homicide. This
track blew up in July of 2022, and shortly after he signed a
record deal to Interscope. He continued releasing music, opened
for SZA on his tour. He also got to do that track Feel It for
Invincible, a song that fans absolutely loved. He had a Fortnite
collab song called Locked and Loaded. And overall, it seemed
like he had a cool, likable vibe and personality, which is why
everyone was shocked when Ah, I don't know if that's true. I
know quite a few women who like heard the music, saw the music
videos, and were like, "Oh, that's disturbing."
That's actually disturbing. This guy talks about killing women
all the time. That's weird. That's weird, bro. the news dropped
that he was linked to a murder. When the news first came out,
it was reported that there was a body in It turns out, listen,
the core concept of this Ryan Beard song, all right, is that
why the [__] would you sing about something you fantasize
about and then get accused of doing the thing you fantasize about?
And then, what are we supposed to believe you didn't do it? In
my [music and singing] Tesla, you will find so many skeletons
of canines,
but that [singing] has nothing to do with [music] me. My opps
put them there to frame me. When it's like all of these circumstances
lining up, it turns out Ryan Beard, the core concept of that
song, the core premise, was totally correct. Yeah, if you sing
about killing your girlfriend all the time and then your girlfriend
shows up decomposing in your Tesla,
probably you did it. And really, the argument that like, "Oh,
it's just music and it it doesn't mean anything." Well, that's
stupid. That's really stupid. in his car that had been in there
for an extended period of time before being found. It was too
badly decomposed to be identified. Apparently, the car had been
at the impound lot for a few days. This was after the car had
been abandoned a few days before that without ever being reported
missing. According to NBC, a spokesperson for David said he has
been informed about what's happened, and although he's still
out on tour, he's fully cooperating with the authorities. But
he would have been touring for over a month before the body was
discovered according to his tour dates, which is why like I said,
most people figured it couldn't have possibly been him. On top
of that, the LAPD said it is one of several vehicles owned by
the musician. Hold on. Yeah, I agree. Just skip the trial. Yeah,
I am out. Just skip the trial. Nobody's saying that. It's just
like there are a lot of people who are saying, "Oh, it's absurd
to think he would have killed this girl." It's like, "No, it's
not. It's actually not even a little bit absurd. It's actually
totally logical to think he killed this girl." Still have to
prove your case. You still go to court. Still get your day in
court and are presumed innocent by the court system. For everybody
in public Dude, I believe he did it. with many different people
using any of the vehicles at any given time. The police didn't
arrest him or anything, and he just went on to perform like normal
the same night handing out labooboos to the crowd. But then things
took a turn for the much worse when the body was identified.
Mhm. And now some breaking news on a major story that we've been
following. We have just learned the identity of a teen found
dead inside of the trunk of a Tesla registered to the singer
David. Investigators now say that the victim, Celeste Rivas,
reported as a runaway last year, had not been seen >> It
was the body of a young girl named Celeste, who would have just
turned 15 years old. She went missing back in April of 2024 when
she was 13. So, she was missing for over a year. Of course, this
in and of itself doesn't directly link her to David, but TMZ
interviewed the girl's mom, who said that her daughter had a
shh tattoo on her right index finger in red ink. Well, David
also had the same tattoo on his right index finger. And this
tattoo isn't unique to David. I mean, Rihanna, Lindsay Lohan,
and Lily Allen also have it. But what makes things miles worse
is that the Bro, okay, what makes things wild miles worse? I
wonder if we're going to find out was this the girl he was streaming
with? That was definitely Celeste, right? I think it's in the
TMZ article here. This stream right here. This stream specifically
was like weird, MAN. OH, YO, YO, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT. And like this
is a clip that was there, and people were like, "Oh, that's Celeste."
Some people didn't think so.
But I don't know, man.
I don't know. >> Oh, look at it. And so, that one that's
so mean if you don't answer it. Which one? Which one? Which one?
That was her left hand that's going up. I wonder if you get a
chance to see her right hand here in the stream. Also, I don't
think there are archives of these streams,
Dude, we went through all this stuff. There's like way more information
making it very clear that these two were together, by the way.
Like tons of Discord logs about the relationship and Letting
your 13-year-old get a tattoo? Well, I wonder if the 13-year-old
had if the mother had a choice or if the 13-year-old went somewhere
with David and they just gave her the tattoo. The mom claimed
her daughter had a boyfriend named David. Right after this news
came out, David canceled his show. TMZ confirmed that a house
that David was living in was being searched by the LAPD. The
house itself was being rented by his manager from Interscope,
but there are tons of pictures with him in the house over the
past year. Apparently, LAPD homicide detectives searched the
house Wednesday and walked out with a computer and several evidence
bags. The only other thing we know is that there was a photo
of David taken just a brief walk from near where the victim originally
lived. The person who posted the picture was alleging that David
was paying people off, but there isn't any concrete proof on
that. All we know for sure is that he was in the area. At the
time I made my video covering this, this was all of the official
information that we had from the police. However, internet detectives
did find a weird amount of coincidences. For example, there were
a bunch of people in his Discord server who were apparently aware
of his connection to Celeste. There were also a bunch of alleged
photos of them together and even a stream clip of them together.
There was a weird Reddit post from a guy who said, "A close friend's
little sister from the LA ran away last year and this is who
she was with." This was posted, by the way, before all this came
out. Dude, there is so much of this [__] going on.
It was actually really cool to look at, too. Like, just knowing
seeing all the information that came out there,
It was It was like crazy just how much linking there was. Given
the fact that this girl was 13 when they met or possibly younger
when they met even, that she went missing when she was 13.
Okay? Insane. Oh, so it seemed almost too on the nose to not
be true. There was a song that leaked that had her name as the
title. There were weird old tweets that were brought into question
and there was a bunch more that I covered in detail in that video.
But despite all of this being speculation, it still looked really
bad. Dude, it's unironically like the drill rap where he's like
singing about the crimes he's going to commit, the crimes he
has committed, right?
It's like the same thing as the Jacksonville drill rap scene
where you just sing about the the literal crimes you're planning
to do.
Oh, Celeste. Oh, Celeste. >> David, I mean, in my opinion,
at the very least it looked apparently clear that he was guilty
of having a relationship with a 13-year-old girl and he was like
20 at the time or something like that. So, disgusting. But, was
he responsible for her death? Well, let's see where the investigation
is at today. The most recent news we have is that David is actually
a suspect and is under investigation. His family was summoned
to testify in front of a court and this revealed that while he
isn't an official suspect or hasn't been charged, they are looking
into him. His family has been challenging the summon to court
saying that the court ordered Mr. Burke to travel across the
country to appear before a California grand jury without ever
allowing him to see the full documents that justify the extraordinary
compulsion. They also live in Texas which might be part of the
reason they don't want to go. Regardless, the police and the
courts have taken efforts to make sure that nothing about this
case goes public, especially as they investigate, which could
make sense because of how >> Dude, it's actually totally
crazy to me that David got arrested on a Tuesday. It's now Thursday
night. He got arrested in California.
I assume in LA and TMZ didn't hear about
That has to be the most insane level of opsec from the cops.
If you get arrested in California and you're a D-list celebrity,
your face is on TMZ within 30 seconds.
How the [__] did they keep this under
TMZ have their staff? Yeah, BUT THEY GOT TO HAVE TONS of people
on the ground in California, in LA.
Right, Luwally? I understand they're in Washington, maybe their
staff is in DC now. They've got to have tons of people on the
ground in Hollywood.
That's like their primary thing, no? TMZ pivoted to politics?
Why am I reading a TMZ article about David being arrested then?
There's no way they they pivoted that hard to politics. It's
not possible.
Anyway, it's just so crazy that just you got arrested in LA and
they didn't know about it, man. high-profile this case is. For
example, the LA County Medical Examiner's office was told not
to reveal any details about Celeste's death to the public. And
the medical examiners aren't happy about this either, saying
"Security holds are virtually unheard of in other countries and
has not been proven to improve outcomes in the legal system."
Regardless of all this, David's family's appeal to challenge
the subpoena was denied, so they will have to testify. And because
of them challenging it, some people think that means they know
a little bit about the situation. Lauren Conlin, a journalist
for Los Angeles Magazine, has been following this case closely
and believes that David's family testifying is crucial and that
the reason no one has been indicted or named as a suspect is
because they are waiting to hear from his family first, which
would imply David is a strong contender for a >> So, as
of now, March 10th, they Now, the funny thing is what happened
is I It seems like David's friends his friends his friend and
his manager turned on him and and actually gave him away. I wonder
what Dude, this could be really cool to hear the inside workings
of this case cuz it sounds like the other people turned on him,
right? And like it took it took a long time. It's been a year.
Well, no, sorry. It's been
7 months? 7 months they've been investigating this for now? >> have
not testified. That is just right now. That could change at any
time. But previously,
we were under the impression over here at Los Angeles Magazine
that the grand jury would be convening through February and by
March, we might see an indictment. I believe that we have not
seen one yet because the testimony of David's family is very
very important and this is my opinion. I'm going to give you
a couple reasons why I believe their testimony is dire. Number
one, the transfer of property. David transferred some of his
assets to his mother. Whose idea was this? Was it her idea? Was
it his idea? How did he explain this? Did they email about this?
Was there money exchanged? I want more details. When did that
happen? >> Two. I want to know when that happened. >> there
a time when David possibly called his parents excessively, emailed
them excessively. I'm thinking Phone records and stuff? >> Okay,
that makes sense. trouble and he didn't know what to do. Sometimes
we call our parents. Well, I want to know. And number three,
his family could establish a timeline. They maybe could tell
us a time when David randomly or sporadically flew home to Texas
out of the blue. What was he like? Did he seem upset? Was he
in Uh Law&Crime have a bunch of videos going over the private
investigator's subpoenas, grand jury, his friend and manager,
and the fight between the Morgan Police Department. Well, I don't
know how much any of that is weighing in. It seems like it's
mostly based on his friend's testimony is what I've seen is they
flipped on him. His friend and his manager both flipped on him,
seemingly. That's what TMZ is saying,
That where do we get the picture of the manager here or the the
friend?
So, putting
David's arrest comes after the grand jury heard testimony from
multiple witnesses in his orbit, including his day-to-day manager,
Robert Morganroth, and his close friend, streamer Neo Langston.
LAPD sources have told TMZ David made a mysterious trip to a
a remote area of Santa Barbara in the middle of the night last
spring and they believe that is somehow connected to Celeste's
disappearance. That could be forensic evidence, right? That if
they know you went out to some area, they got like some mud,
some [__] they could tie to that area from that night,
tied to like her corpse in some way. Yeah.
It's pretty interesting. I wonder if they're just getting like
bits and pieces. Man, I need to know. I need to know now. I need
to know
I'm excited. injured? Did they look at his car? Did they look
at his clothes? Did they notice anything funny? These are just
three reasons that I believe their testimony is so important,
but there are a lot more reasons other than what I just listed.
>> also a guy named Neo Langston, a social media influencer,
who's been seen with
>> David's friend and key witness in case of girl's death
arrested in Montana and returned to LA. This would be 3 weeks
ago. who was arrested and bailed out of jail in January this
year. But this didn't provide too much insight. According to
IB Times, he made some weird posts on Instagram and they said
his tone appeared defiant as he dismissed any lingering legal
jeopardy regarding his recent detention. "Thankfully, I'm legally
fine in every way and boy, do I got all my receipts for things.
Haha." This suggests Neo has documented proof like a
Bro, everybody in this sphere is just Darius with more money.
They're all They're all like just
All of them. They're like the exact same like anime sad boy archetype
that posts like were totally to so social media. Like actually
just with their own court cases and stuff. It's very funny. that
could influence the murder investigation. I told so many people
that I trust and I thought knew me as a person, my side of things,
all for that to be thrown out the window as soon as I got arrested.
I wonder if he is the primary suspect or if it's, you know, if
he's accessory in some way. It says arrested for murder.
So, I'm I'm guessing at minimum accessory in some way.
Honestly, just based on the songs and based on the relationship,
I can't think of a reason one of his friends would have killed
the 14-year-old girl and then he'd help cover it up, you know
what I'm saying? It feels like it has to be the other way around.
That's the only way you get them like even staying quiet for
as long as they did is is his friends are like they know he's
their meal ticket, so they're going to support him or or cover
for him in some way. And they slapped that dickhead's name next
to mine. The investigative grand jury made that people looking
into the case right now have had people like David's manager
in and out of the building to testify, so that's also a little
bit of an insight. Regardless though, we still don't know too
much about this case. Investigators are keeping everything under
wraps and it's possible that they're maybe not trying to scare
away suspects into running out of the country. On top of this,
David hasn't been seen or said a peep since all of this came
out, which also makes sense. All we really know is that investigators
are looking into David as a potential suspect and if his family
does end up testifying soon, we could end up with an actual indictment
and charges against David or whoever they think is guilty. Anyway,
all we can really hope for is justice for Celeste because this
case is truly horrifying and hopefully they're able to prosecute
everyone involved with the brutal murder of a 14-year-old girl
to the fullest extent of the law. His friend fled the state before
the subpoena and only testified after being brought back on a
warrant. We just heard that in this
Private investigator hired by the house owners found the police
found an industrial burn cage in the house. Okay, if they had
an industrial burn cage or something,
why in the world did they not cremate that body?
They just They They like got all this [__] to do
the crime and cover up their crime and then they just didn't
cover it up? Cuz as far as I know, they parked that car out there
for like weeks. No? I could have sworn they parked that car That
car was like sitting there for a long time. For it to get towed
in a residential area, for you to park your car somewhere and
for that car to get towed, you have to have it sitting there
forever. It was it unopened in the box? They're dumbasses. Oh,
Jesus Christ, man. Like, yeah, okay.
Uh, wait, when did we find out about that? Cuz that makes it
very obvious that they killed so that they killed her and they
It's just whether or not David's connected, right? Hey, go to
Amazon right now and figure out buy this thing that we used to
cremate bodies, get it shipped here, and then it's like sitting
in the box. You've got it on your order history. Did they at
least hide it? Did they at least hide this this cremation box
in their order history?
It's one of the pieces of Well, it sounds like the cops had it.
Star, okay, the most relevant is the fight between the Morgan
Police Department because the TMZ a TMZ morgue insider swears
they found evidence of the body being frozen, and the police
department made a press
statement saying it's not true. So, time of death is the most
interesting part. Okay, so that they might not know it because
she was frozen. Although, yeah, I guess if she was Dude, wait.
Oh my god.
Wouldn't that be insane if they had like an industrial-level
freezer or even just like a deep freeze and she dies? That's
why she goes missing in April, and she's actually just missing
for months and months and months. So, he could be out on tour
when she's found.
So, yes, so you wait to let Dude, did somebody call that Karen
to get it
That would be crazy, right? You like make it so that he's out
touring, he's in a different part of the country when she actually
is found.
Oh my god. Diabolical stuff. That would be crazy.